Jenna did you say so much Canada or you
love Canada I said both at the same time
perfect
um first of all I'm such a huge fan of
the screen franchise and honestly screen
six is my favorite film since the
original so I loved it so much uh Jenna
you got to punch Gail weathers what was
that whole scene like that was a long
time coming I'll tell you
Courtney just the entire time we're
going
that was that was real that was actually
improvised yeah that was an incredible
experience I feel like the way that that
was scripted in the way that that went
down was really
um epic yeah epic is such a good word
it's just one of the many scenes that
were really funny and such an amazing
you know not I guess to the first film
um this movie is Scary like I was kind
of closing my eyes in the theater at 10
A.M when I was watching it uh it's funny
there's so much stabbing Melissa if you
had to guess how many times you and
Jenna stab someone in this film what
would be the number
be in the 50s
yeah we tried to count yeah at some
point it's ridiculous yeah because I
know that like this movie starts and I
say I stabbed him 22 times since right
so like we we counted the ones in the
last movie and I know they wanted more
in this one so they just let me go for
it and it I had I had shoulder pain
after after that day I'm not gonna lie I
was going to ask you that's really
involved yeah it was glorious to watch
were you a little jealous you wanted to
stab a bit more I was very jealous yeah
I wish I stabbed a couple more people
Jenna does get one of the best
one-liners though in the entire movie
yeah I got pretty lucky yeah can we
share the one-liner
version
oh yeah that's it I say now die a
virgin yeah
such a good scene I know what you're
talking about now at the end yeah yeah
please watch them please
it's so good okay so out of the two of
you in real life if you had to go up
against Ghost space who do you think
would survive and who would be the goner
Melissa Melissa is one of the strongest
people I know I feel like you would
survive too
I feel like you could get away from him
I feel like I would just be really
annoying like you'd probably get tired
of me
take him down take the knife kill me
he'd be like just kill me I'll be like
you took you long enough
amazing I mean that could work
um Jenna talking to Canadians I know
you're working with the weekend on a new
movie which obviously you can't say a
lot about but what's been your favorite
thing about working with him so far
um well what I can say about able is
he's genuinely such a sweetheart uh I
instantly comfortable instantly um he's
just he's very respectful and and very
um yeah I don't know very collaborative
I guess you can say which when you're
working on a set especially with um the
the team on that project is is really
really wonderful and
um I I think that you know sometimes you
don't really know how much you could say
but they've all been collaborative and
and wanting to know my voice and my
opinion and that's always a really
wonderful feeling when you're stepping
onto a set for the first time I love
hearing that all right well I can't wait
to see that and honestly I'm sure you've
already seen the reviews people are
loving Scream Six so congrats guys oh is
this the exciting again we love eats in
Canada
to every outlet that comes in no you're
the only one with the name
Morgan we were talking about you before
we came in and you're our favorite we
decided favorite person favorite place
yeah stop out of the core four you two
are my favorite
thank you out of us too who's your
favorite
I'm going Jasmine Jasmine for sure thank
you you didn't have to say it but you
did that's great you knew you just knew
okay
so good I I think this is my favorite
movie out of the franchise except the
first one obviously that's still you
know the hardcore original but this
one's so good not to pin you two against
each other but I'm going to who do you
think of the two of you would survive
ghost space in real life real life or in
real life in real life I assume I don't
know you would see the thing about
Jasmine you wouldn't engage no I'm out
I'm like you wouldn't engage you would
run I'm leaving if you asked who would
win in a fist fight with Ghostface I
probably have a better leg up my muscles
are slightly smaller but uh even though
it is questionable but Jasmine would
survive
I would want to know you said Ghostface
on the way I'm in London yeah I'm not
here until British Ghost Face comes out
of nowhere suddenly I'm in Jamaica
wait can we make this happen absolutely
I really like that I would love that I
love that too okay well not your makeup
but obviously Woodsboro to New York City
why is the Big Apple such a fun
playground for Ghostface
because there's so many more people so
many more places way more opportunities
for Ghostface to appear to slash and
dash and dead but he does he he's this
Dasher
um you also have so many different in
terms of like a entertainment property
so many different ways to kill people
and yes in a in New York
which is a weird way of thinking about
New York it's just like a kill ground
but um I think the movie uses its Locale
really well
it's funny because we even saw it in the
trailer with the subway scene but that
scene watching it in the movie still
scared the crap out of me it was gone I
haven't been able to take the subway
since then oh but you know what shout
out to our incredible crew on this film
because that was all on a Sound Stage
that's right they built that subway car
and they built that platform can you
believe it was real they tried they
tried to bring one in and apparently 50
tons it's too heavy for the students way
more than that that only be 120 000
pounds it was like 600 tons
just build it and make it fully operable
listen it was so good and on a scale of
one to ten how much do we love ghost
face with a shotgun
what do you mean by love because it's
terrifying yeah I think but it is for
the fans like for the fans and it's
pretend yeah
um solid 9.9 only because he didn't say
something ridiculous when he pulls the
trigger because if he says something
like something like pop up guess who
yeah not more like that would have been
epic or just something like Shama Lama
Ding Dong and then I go I'd be like New
Yorkers
I want to come hang out with you guys on
set this is the professional waiting for
come to the camera okay uh guys thanks
so much honestly I I know you've
probably read the reviews but so good
thank you thanks guys hey Dermot Hi how
are you I am good you've appeared in
some of my favorite movies of all time
My Best Friend's Wedding the Family
Stone so it was so much fun for me to
see my favorite franchise was this
an immediate yes for you this was an
immediate yes I was a scream fan from
the beginning I missed a couple of the
middle movies but of course okay I
caught up when I got this part so that I
was uh right up to speed and really one
of the cool things about the scream
storyline is it's never stopped even if
they took 10 years off here and there
that was just enough time for them to
figure out their next move I mean the
writers the guys that kicked this uh
franchise on and on and I'm not just
saying this I'm such a huge fan of the
franchise I think this is my favorite
movie since the first one this one's
good well we're all thrilled with it and
I say we because they include me in
their group
um uh that already established
themselves as great friends Melissa and
Jenna uh Mason and Jasmine Hayden
um and so to be included with the cast
that's already friends in a movie that's
already uh a fan favorite was really
just uh incredibly lucky for me you know
it's fun for us too you get to reunite
with Courtney Cox after appearing on
three episodes of friends in season nine
what was more intimidating walking on
the set of friends or walking on the set
of screen
oh easy answer they're much more
intimidating on the set of friends yeah
yeah yeah and it was a huge hit at the
time as this is so let's let's figure
this out there's some similarities of
course but that for me especially at the
time was a different format of acting
sitcom on a stage with three cameras at
once I've done it maybe once before but
um so it was a tried and true show they
were all you know on the rails
incredible ninth season peaking uh so I
felt uh like a fish out of water um so
so gratified especially in recent years
that those
um that those episodes took on a little
bit a life of their own
um and that uh you know maybe I did
better on that show than I gave my
self-credit for at the time so it's nice
to let that
um you know mature a little bit Yeah
well that is nice too because you know
especially over the past couple years
people became obsessed with friends all
over again and then this new one that's
what I noticed happening too that it hit
a whole new audience and then the same
if not more appreciation for the humor
in that Series so it took on a second a
second life that was totally unexpected
when I met Courtney uh shooting Scream
Six when I met her again
um we definitely laughed about that and
uh it was great to see her after many
years I love that okay so I'm probably
gonna get the wrap soon but I've been
asking everybody on set how do you think
you would handle coming up against
Ghostface would you be a goner or do you
think you'd be a survivor
I don't know it's it's tough to say I
think uh yeah no I'd probably be a goner
um wow maybe just maybe I don't know
they're so fast Jenna you should see how
fast
um the these actors can run yeah uh
Melissa too a terrific athlete and um
um yeah I think uh probably gone or
maybe just maybe Ghost Face a trip on
that unwieldy
um cloak that he wears right just maybe
if it was your luck just maybe I also
great singing this congratulations
thank you sure appreciate it thank you